one of my staffers brought some tweets
of yours to my attention and uh I
thought I needed to we should discuss it
maybe here's a tweet that you sent out
it is weird that my celebrity crush is
ten percent absolutely at Conan O'Brien
is that weird is it
all day this is the problem here is all
of thee is that weird right don't freak
out but guess who it is Conan O'Brien do
you have to qualify it that much I mean
your staff is amazing by the way they're
like Internet sleuths because that was
you posted that a while ago yeah you
didn't do that in anticipation of this
show we've got a long time ago my
question is why can't if someone said
I've got a crush on Brad Pitt they don't
go isn't that crazy question mark
question mark question mark because they
know that the general reactions gonna be
like yeah that's right but you act like
your tweet is gonna blow up the universe
it's so I think that was more of me
channeling my teenage self you know you
get a little nervous and like is it
weird weird okay there's like five
emojis up oh yeah oh the emoji I don't
know why they're all the emojis are all
crying and sweating I'm just saying that
there's there's a lot about that that
doesn't make me feel good then there's
another one I think we have it used to
be hard to have a STONER and Ben Affleck
but Cohn is definitely taking the lead
both tall dark and handsome so then I'm
thinking you don't even have the right
guy somebody else at least dark first
thing I'm the whitest human being on the
planet you know that Conan ladies he's
so dark and handsome so baby I don't
know what else to say okay I went out of
three ain't bad
my celebrity crush is Ben Affleck but
back in Good Will Hunting days okay you
liked him back then yeah Shia LaBeouf
back in transformers days right the
Conan O'Brien all day that's so sweet
I get better with age because of the
surgeries I always have to take a
compliment and just jam it down into the
toilet
you